well las vegas's newest resort is now
open
for business throughout the day folks
have been getting a glimpse of the new
resorts world
joe moeller back out live on the strip
with reaction about the incredible
property joe
yeah hey there's a lot of people are
making their way to the north end of the
strip to check out resorts world
is now open for business before today
this area wasn't as busy but
throughout the day we have been noticing
a lot of people coming up here
just look inside it is easy to notice
the increase in foot traffic in front of
the resort last night was the first
night guests stayed in the hotel
people say they are impressed by the
casino the technology and all those
rooms
ryan mccormick stayed the night and he
says he will be back
been to vegas quite a few times and it's
nice to see you know some luxury coming
in like this it was
it was great a lot of uh food options
entertainment options oscar
what's your favorite
this weekend will be busy for the 3000
room resort the luxury crockford's brand
appeared to be sold out online this
evening
other rooms at the hilton and conrad
brands for tonight are running around
400 to 500 now back out here live we're
taking another look at
some of the folks who are just uh coming
to this area of the north end of the
strip the sidewalks are all open now so
people were able to walk
circus circus and walk down this way to
resorts world but the
the construction is not done just yet
there's still the day club of the
nightclub they're working on and also
the theater but those clubs will be open
next week
when those events are planned for
independence day reporting live here on
the strip joe morgan 8 news now